J. R. R. Tolkien's "The Lord of the Rings"
trilogy is one of the most important works
of fantasy ever written, and is a touchstone
upon which many of today's fantasy worlds and
creatures are based. The world of Middle-earth
gained even more popularity when Peter Jackson
adapted "The Lord of the Rings" into a film series
that managed to capture its unique appeal, and the
settings and characters that Tolkien created
have continued finding new fans to this day.
Much of the appeal of "The Lord of the Rings"
comes from the impressive cast of characters
that Tolkien conjured up for his timeless fantasy
saga. At the core of these is Frodo Baggins, and
Samwise Gamgee, his steadfast and loyal friend.
Sam begins the story as a risk-averse gardener…
"If I take one more step, it'll be the
farthest away from home I've ever been."
… but by the end of the tale,
he's been transformed into a
legendary hero on the same level as
any among the Fellowship of the Ring.
It's perhaps for this reason that J.R.R. Tolkien
considered Samwise Gamgee to be the true hero of
"The Lord of the Rings", remarking in a letter
to potential publisher Milton Waldman in 1951,
"I think the simple 'rustic' love of
Sam and his Rosie [...] is absolutely
essential to the study of his
(the chief hero's) character…"
Tolkien's assertion that Sam is the "chief hero"
is probably no surprise to Lord of the Rings fans.
Though Frodo Baggins takes on the task of bearing
the One Ring to Mount Doom, he begins to falter
over the course of his long journey, eventually
deciding to take the ring for himself when it
finally comes time to destroy it. Meanwhile,
Sam's time with the ring sees him single-mindedly
devoted to saving Frodo, and he never even
considers keeping the cursed object for himself.
Sam overcomes his humble beginnings to defeat
a giant spider. He also slays a tower full of
Orcs to rescue Frodo and is so formidable
an opponent that the Orcs believe him to be
a legendary Elven warrior. Finally, when Frodo
can no longer walk, it's Sam who carries him up
Mount Doom so that he can complete his task.
Still, there's even more to Sam than this.
"Samwise the Brave. I want to hear more about
Sam. Frodo wouldn't have got far without Sam."
J.R.R. Tolkien had some real-life heroes in
mind when he created the character of Sam,
as reflected in a 1956 letter to
editor H. Cotton Minchin, which read,
“My ‘Samwise’ is indeed (as you note)
largely a reflexion of the English soldier…"
Notably, Tolkien served in the British
military during World War I and as such,
witnessed great acts of heroism firsthand.
The author admired these soldiers so
deeply that he wrote that they were,
quote, "so far superior to [him]." When a
man with the same name as the heroic Hobbit
wrote to Tolkein in 1956, Tolkien said that it
was an honor to have that name, writing back,
"The 'Sam Gamgee' of my story is a most heroic
character [...] even though
his origins are rustic."
With these words in mind, it's
clear that Tolkien admired Sam
just as much as readers and viewers
have come to for generations since.